j'ai très bien imaginer première
question premier répond avec les deux
noms je la pose aux deux en fin soirée
de concerts de la première je pense
qu'elle te concernant a pu être plus toi
c'est à dire que un jour je décide de
faire un enfant et puis tu t'aperçois
que tu peux plus en avoir pour des
raisons tu peux plus en avoir
et tu cherches une mère porteuse et
lierait il m'a tuer te propose d'être ta
mère porteuse est ce que tu as fait pour
ce que tu refuses l'a d'abord je vais
faire un test hil du sida oui jusqu'à
way et sinon oui mais pas de problème
quant à non pourquoi
non je sais pas je te demande c'est une
question deuxième question est à toi si
tu veux trouver quoi ça correspond
peut-être un peu mieux aussi qu à qui tu
trouve le plus de circonstances
atténuantes à un dieu qui se cachent des
petits garçons pour de l'argent ou un
petit garçon qui se tapent sur des vieux
toujours pour de l'argent
aucun aucun aucun du cirque en société
dont je suis très moral finalement fin
et hu a avancé lui répond tu répètes
d'accord c'est qu'on rigole heures à toi
maintenant à quoi est-ce que tu serais
prêt à mourir maintenant lacaune otages
subitement 30/4 ailleurs fille nina
simone pour que l'appareil soit
immédiatement supprimées en afrique du
sud
non pas que c'est là l'autre jour tu as
posé une question sur la faim dans le
monde
en entrevue dix mois pour moi tu es
prête à mourir si on peut le faire à
l'engagement des structures là toute la
planète pour un pays ça va mal comment
ça va faire plaisir aux housses
alors imaginez êtes tous les jours dans
un chalet ce book c'est bien qu'on ait
lieu vous êtes tous les deux ans dans un
chalet de montagne puis lui les morts
qu'il soit en août à bouffer je le mange
mais tu commences par contre oui
d'accord mais tu commences parfois c'est
ça la connaît à la perfection la tête
parce que comme ça au moins je ne
paierai plus la cervelle non la figure
oh non mais avec une bonne tasse au juge
oui parce que prévu debbiche vous êtes
morts tous les deux vous préfère un
carré en stone et charden yoko agent ou
pierre et marie curie carré marie
queyroi pourquoi je m'en sers yo yo
corps
alors question qu'on traditionnel la
bande arrive dans la minute qui suit moi
je me tapais un gars de jack daniel's je
fais un grand baie à 4
et puis voilà tétouan 4 ric3 devant le
baiser giannoli alors pour la laver
parce que vous avez une solution c'est
vous échapper juste avant la barre il y
avait redit ne vous appelle vous écouter
les gens quand on a laissé crever tout
le monde on vous met dans un vaisseau
spatial vous qu'à pied sur la lune
format sepa ou là où c'est bien voilà il
n'y a pas de bombe mais il ya trois
places dans des seaux spatiale et comme
gardienne ils vont vous en prie un
troisième passage chez renault c'est
bien faire on a eu nos gueules
maintenons ppda guy dussault savait-il
france sabatier froid ah ben ouais
pourquoi guy lux il arrête pas de il est
trop peur maggie vidéo est trop
sérieuses a battu le harfang darabont
c'est ce que je vous dis vidéo avec le
sourire